[موسيقى]
يأتي حبنا لتناول الطعام الفاخر بتكلفة
إهدار الطعام لرؤية الطعام في شعاع ،
وهذا دائمًا يكسر ثروة حوالي
3.2 مليار دولار من الطعام
يضيع كل عام في دولة الإمارات العربية
المتحدة ، وهي دولة تستورد 95٪ من
احتياجاتها  الطعام الذي يبلغ حوالي 200 كيلوغرام
للفرد ضعف المعدل في أوروبا
وأمريكا الشمالية في مطبخ الشيف أودو بدبي ،
وهو نظام جديد عالي التقنية
نعلم أنه شركة
توفر أدوات ذكاء اصطناعي
لمساعدة الطهاة في إدارة مطابخ أكثر ربحية ،
ولدينا نظام
يوجد في أعلى الصندوق ، يحتوي النظام
على كاميرا في كل مرة تقوم فيها برمي شيء
بعيدًا ، يتعرف النظام على ما هو
يلتقط صورة ويتعلم من
الصور بمرور الوقت ، تعود كل البيانات التي يتم
جمعها إلى الطهاة أو
مديري الإنتاج في  أمام
تقرير لا يضيع ما يتم
إهداره وعندما يمكنهم اتخاذ الإجراءات في
اليوم التالي لخفض هدر الطعام ،
يقول الغرب إنهم يعملون في أكثر من 100
مطبخ في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.  إن مجد الشيف
يضيف إلى عنوان bhai's downtown hotel الذي
نعرفه يقول إنهم يقيسون تأثيرهم من
خلال عدد الوجبات التي
يوفرونها.تريد الشركة توفير 3 ملايين وجبة
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة وحدها بحلول العام المقبل ، نحن
بالفعل في حوالي 1.7 مليون وجبة ، لذا
عليك الذهاب إلى  سرير كل ليلة مع العلم
أنك توفر 1.7 مليار وجبة من
سلة المهملات في الإمارات العربية المتحدة وحدها ، وهذا أمر
مذهل ، كان أكبر مطور عقاري في دبي ،
أمار ، من أوائل
الشركات التي تنشر تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي الرابحة ،
والآن تعمل أرملة على توسيع نطاق هذه
التكنولوجيا في جميع أنحاء العالم.  re
تعمل حاليًا في 40 دولة وتتطلع إلى
التوسع نعلم أنها توفر لعملائها
حوالي 30 مليون دولار سنويًا
بهدف توفير مليار دولار بحلول
عام 2025 مما يساعد على ضمان أن عمل
الطهاة مثل الجودو لم يعد ينتهي
بسبعة أرقام فقط.  وظيفة آنا ستيوارت
سي إن إن